in a largely unarmed society scenes like
these
stand out
gunmen participating in a military
parade in the jeannine refugee camp in
northern occupied west bank
they're taking part in a memorial for 14
palestinians killed in jeanine during
the past two months
at least half of the 14 were killed in
an exchange of fire with the israeli
army
including two gunmen who shot eight
people dead in two separate attacks
inside israel
the israeli army said it wants family
members of one of the gunmen
but they're taking refuge in the camp
where dozens of fighters live
even though these fighters are wanted by
the israeli army they're here in a show
of force that is filled with symbolism
one of the headbands here says the wasps
nest this is how israeli media refers to
the camp
armed men speaking exclusively to al
jazeera say they're reclaiming the
description
we live under occupation they confiscate
our lands raid our homes and kill our
people what should we do remain silent
even those who are not fighting the
occupation yet give them some time and
they will fight
the flags of different palestinian
factions show the collaboration between
groups here but outside the camp this
kind of agreement is hard to find
one gunman told al jazeera that fighters
feel let down by palestinian and other
arab leaders
we don't have real support given the
current internal palestinian divisions
those men you see now in janine refugee
camp and some other places are just lone
wolves who believe in the justice of
their cause
a lot of fighters weren't even born when
the israeli army carried a violent raid
in the camp 20 years ago but they wear
headbands remembering what is known here
as the jeanine battle
52 palestinians and 23 israeli soldiers
were killed during the 2002 incursion
into the camp many here say while that
battle is now over
the war is not
jamal will was a fighter in the janine
camp during that battle
these are archived videos of him 20
years ago
his book about the jeanine battle was
just released last month
we have a lot of people who are killed
or detained there's not one house in the
camp that doesn't have a personal story
for the struggle against the occupation
young children grow up with pictures of
relatives killed by israeli forces this
affects the generations conscious and
subconscious
this is the motorbike of abdallah
he's a palestinian who was killed by the
israeli forces fire in early march and
we were talking to many people who say
they were inspired by him we're seeing
some of the iron men carrying pictures
of palestinians who were young
fire it's not hard to tell
many of the gunmen here acknowledge the
israeli army has the military advantage
but they say they want to create a
reality where the strongest army in the
middle east pays a price for its
occupation they say israel left them
with two choices surrender or fight
and they're not surrendering
nida ibrahim al-jazeera jeanine refugee
camp occupied west bank